[Applause]
[Music]
Billy eilish honors late Foo Fighters
drummer Taylor Hawkins at her La concert
you know just in the short time of
meeting him a few times it felt like you
know we lost a friend the singer also
took a moment to remember Stephen twitch
boss who died by Suicide earlier this
week
[Music]
on Thursday night Taylor's bandmate Dave
Grohl joined Billy on stage as a
surprise guest the pair performed a
tribute to Taylor who died in March
after a fatal overdose they did an
acoustic rendition of a Foo Fighters
classic my hero
was filled with real tears of love and
gratitude so
from our families who are here tonight
Hawkins family
and everyone
[Music]
we'd like to thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but this isn't the first time Billy's
paid tribute to Taylor at the Grammys in
April the bad guy singer rocked a
t-shirt with the drummer's face during
her performance with her brother Phineas
what a legendary performer and you know
somebody we were inspired by and fans of
long before we got a chance to know him
and yeah we only met him a couple times
I wish we'd gotten a chance to know him
even better but yeah we're devastated
devastated you know just in the short
time of meeting him a few times it felt
like you know we lost a friend and it
was such a genuine kind like generous
dude sometimes people are are so
generous with their energy that they
give you and they're they're just like
the shortest moment where somebody can
feel like a really big moment really
important just such a sweet guy and we
just you know it's my heart breaks for
his family and his friends during her La
concert Billy also talked about twitch
who was found dead in his motel room
Tuesday where he died of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound the singer
expressed although she didn't know him
well she misses him and feels for his
family we love to Full House and also
just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean shortly
after news broke of the dancer's death
tributes came flooding in from his
famous friends Viola Davis and Quest
love tweeting they're at a loss for
words while Sierra shared this clip
dancing with twitch at The Ellen Show
writing that she's crushed
[Music]
and just hours after twitch's wife
Allison holker announced his death the
couple's longtime friend Jody Sweetin
got emotional reflecting on twitch's
Legacy I'm still in a lot of shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah he's such a talent and such an
amazing warm wonderful heart and uh yeah
he will be he will be greatly missed
[Music]